[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zum verlies welt
heute gibt es drei rezepte und zwar habe
ich grundrezepte für saucen diese soße
mich an meine schokosoße eine
karamellsoße und eine vanillesoße
die könnt ihr benutzten führt zum
beispiel waffeln für ein muffin für
pancakes oder für ganz viele andere
desserts befinden und rezepte und ihr
könnt ihr auch super vorbereiten und
dann im kühlschrank lagern
ich zeige mich jetzt einfach mal gleich
die erste große das ist die schokosoße
und habe starten wollen einfachsten lose
anders die schokoladensauce dafür
brauche ich nur zwei zutaten für die
schokosoße brauche ich 200 milliliter
sahne und 100 km herren schokolade sahne
die kommt in einen topf und daraus ist
aufkochen und sobald die den kopf
hinhält abgibt die schokolade mit
achtung und würde so lange bis die
schokolade dahingeschmolzen ist
[Musik]
die post ab kühl und in dieser zeit kann
ich schon mal die vanilla tafel zu
bereiten für die vanilleschote brauche
ich schon nach 75 milliliter milch eine
freie fläche zucker und einen halben
teelöffel stärke etwas manila extrakt
unter blog gibts noch karamellisierte
apfelspalten dann nehme ich einen apfel
etwas zitronensaft
hinzu kommen nämlich besser mal die
milch kommt in einem topf und da gebe
ich jetzt vanille extrakt mit dazu ihr
könnt ja auch eine vanilleschote nehmen
aber wandel extrakt besteht auch von der
schotte nach vanille konsum partnerin
daher nehme ich das immer ganz gerne
weil man gut erklären kann zucker und
stärke mit 7 klatsche wird
[Musik]
habe ich alles im griff und jetzt werde
ich den herzen habe ich jetzt auf stufe
gestellt und immer weiter um das foyer
vanillesoße und den einblicken in der
zwischenzeit habe ich hier schon mal ein
paar apfelspalten geschliffen und schöne
zähne spalten und direkt hier im japaner
karamellisieren
seit wir hier mit dem zucker drum ein
bisschen zitronensaft an gft ist eine
ganz kleine zitrone die presse
[Musik]
sobald das super hier zu parallelisieren
beginnt vom die äpfel mit 3 und werden
einfach ein paar minuten mit
angebrachten mit von nicht verbrennen
[Musik]
und sobald wir ein mal aufgekocht wird
von mir hier ist gefährdet setzte jetzt
unfällen mit einer frischhaltefolie
abdecken damit keine haut bildet und
dann abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
die vanillesoße auch noch abkühlen und
ich zeige euch die dritte große das
karamellsoße murat lieblings dafür
eigentlich mal die zutaten für die
karamell gruppe brauche ich 100
milliliter wasser 200 gramm zucker 300
schlagsahne eine prise salz und zwei
esslöffel butter zuerst wasser um scrum
die kommen gemeinsam in einen topf und
deine anti mischung jetzt aufkochen und
so lange kochen bis sie hell karamell
farben wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
an dieser verlässt man jetzt dass wir
probleme sind immer kleiner werden und
damit jetzt ganz genau aufpassen denn
ganz konnten punkt stellt genau hier
dann fängst an farbig zu werden und dann
müsst ihr echt aufpassen das karamell
jetzt nicht verbrennt das heißt nur hell
karamell fahren denn je dunkler das
karamell wird umso bitterer weil dann
auch die tote sobald dann die farbe
erreicht kommt der metatron hier ist
ganz wichtig dass die daten nicht aus
dem kühlschrank kommt sondern dass es
immer warm oder lauwarm
[Musik]
besser noch dazu doch verstecken süße
aber mindert das gaben sie auch ein
bisschen also die harmlose erschlägt
einem dann nicht so sehr müsse aufpassen
dass nicht überkocht also am besten die
hitze unterstellt ohne vor bald sie ein
gedicht ist und fast die gewünschte
konsistenz erreicht aber ein bisschen
flüssig laufen kommt gleich für
futtermittel
[Musik]
fertig und bereits abwickelt und die
könnte wie gesagt so pancake waffeln eis
oder anderen bisher verlieren ich habe
mir jetzt hier abgepackt und west im
kühlschrank lagern dort sind sie mehrere
tage haltbar
das heißt ihr könnt ihr auch gerne auf
vorbereiten und dann einfach lagern und
bei bedarf herausnehmen
die rezepte nachlesen wollen können wir
gerne auf meinem blog auf bild.de
das geht alles noch mal ganz genau und
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und weise die nach macht
könnt ihr mir gerne ein foto ihres
facebook hat ein foto von eur 1 foto
ersticken auf facebook auf im verkauf
und schaue mir gerne an
also viel spaß beim nachmachen und bis
zum nächsten mal sind willkommen die
pinkel schlank
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und
ende
[Musik]
ich grüße ich meine familie eigentlich
sagt mein ganzer familien zugriffe jetzt
in der frühzeit ich mein papa meine mama
meine schöne grüße ich jetzt noch
demokrat die verlierer die ma dann
künftig noch mehr power translator
fahrrad